this video is brought to you by better
help as three people proud to be in
therapy we are proud to be partner with
them for the month of November citizens
of the reject Nation we are here for the
Loki season 2 finale John how are you I
am terribly
voraciously anticipant all right let's
see Coy how that's right he's running
late of course he is don't worry he'll
be here guys which will give us time to
do a little shout out to everyone who
has bought real rejects merch at www.
reject Nation shop com my guys thank you
so much and ladies for all the support
you have been giving our way and looking
good while doing it we got shirts like
Marvel inspired space babies of the
Galaxy we also got Marvel merch John's
rocking this Loki shirt this other
Marvel shirt but we also got stuff like
Pedro Pascal from Last of Us carrying
baby grou Child Protection Services my
personal Fai but we also got citizen
King we got who influences The
influencers Watchmen inspired we also
got some Ahsoka inspired te's we got
more development got this America's ass
from the boys universe that's another
one of my personal favorites and we got
a whole bunch more either one that you
buy is one of the best ways my personal
favorite way for you to support the
channel so thank you guys so much with
that in mind leave a like on this video
also another thing to thank you all for
for supporting the channel thank you so
much for becoming super sexy rejects
that's where you get the full length
through R and watch along where you syn
with your own copy of Loki and we also
cover several shows exclusively over
there with reaction high and watch
alongs included all righty guys let's
get into action you ready
koi that's son of a
[Music]
[__] I don't notice anything different
about the music nothing what are you
talking
about
Echo backwards damn good
[Music]
catch
cool
they're all
disappearing whoa into the comics we go
this is trippy that was cool into the
pen and inav
verse oh I'm going to miss this show
yeah it's really good yeah
buddy it's hard to be brave is he not
telling them hey is it right now yeah
got it
grab himy how long will he have not long
about this radiation level it's even
worse than when I was out there speak up
loie
more what if we just repeat all of
episode 5 that's the whole
episode oh different
angle okay so we're not just fixing
things I think he has to see how it
failed what could we have done
differently we took too long
oh go back to episode one
again fost they are just he's going to
come to bargain okay no time to argue
okay cool cool get down the gangway load
the multiplier hit the green button
launch it and get back okay it's exactly
way wonder how much failure there's
going to
be instantaneous Ely what happened he's
gone again not faster is it over earlier
wow this is really the Mastery of time
minutes I know right now you're hurt and
you're
angry finishing theit multiplier
fast just in the middle of the nerious
plan oh my God that's
awesome I wasted time and now does time
waste
me oh my god oh before we even get
through the doors I wonder what number
we're
on oh come on come on come on come on
come on steps
no oh that
skeleton again introdu can you time slip
to like he who
remains this is Ora Boris guess what the
TVA handbook you both wrote
it so this model is now finished what
are you talking about it's absolutely
perfect this is like an improv game
where they want you to speed it up why
me because you volunteered you did you
will and you know how the multiplier
Works it'll make sense it will make
sense I love how we've had franticness
so much of this show and now we're
having fun frantic yeah it's like
joyously frantic not as tense Obie how
long will it take me to know everything
that you know about mechanics physics
and Engineering oh my God he's going to
become a genius the god of story is
getting all data but I'm a fast learner
and I'm a God yeah you are how long
would it take
decades
centuries Commit This is like a Doctor
Who episode
wowow yeah is like a Doctor Who episode
low I'm not questioning your
surprisingly Advanced engineering
skills centuries later now it looks
lethal it is absolutely safe watch
this I'll take those thank you when
you're ready chop a man in
control I love how this really does feel
like lowkey show we have to move fast
who's it going to be it's him it's you
you
volunteer what about the IR 9 is fine no
it's not going to overheat because would
allow it to interface directly with
time's adaptive expon ping system it
would allow the loom to scale the
capacity to manage the backlog of
branches Tom H Hillson doesn't even know
what he's talking about
yep he said centuries like watching
someone do Shakespeare it's beautiful
like I don't know what you're saying but
I get cuz you get it don't forget to
latch his helmet that's latch his helmet
thank you thank you does this
Victor accept
he is becoming the king of the TVA if
you stop you
die oh
[__] oh boy five episodes leading to
back to being in the lowkey show was
interesting
oh that was such a great C that pause
was
perfect come on buddy and load the
multiplier into the
launcher that's it one step at a time
got to keep going be brave you're being
so
brave many times you
given bra you're being so
brave that was hilarious is so
good one foot in front of the other
everything he needs to hear before you
know it you'll be at the end of the gang
way what a guide well
done looks on everyone's faces the
nonchalant of the direction oh you made
it not yet yeah seriously how many times
have you gotten this far do not put the
multiplier down it will roll
off Victor come on there it is there it
is push through come on buddy it's just
time it's Lo he who remains wanted
lowkey to be in that's what he offered
him at the end of last season this is
all still him in control this is all
still he who remains plan I feel it it's
all still him watching too like right
here
come on
push
turn there it is oh come on
bud hit the green green right listen to
me carefully I love how there's no
music something's bound to go wrong no
what about that other greenish bluish
green it can be a little
sticky
green y oh my
God yes good POV get back back yes come
back I love you Victor beautiful
beautiful man go go go go go oh the joy
the
[Music]
relief now let's watch Victor become a
villain yeah and now he is K we did it
team oh wait for those doors to close
come on come on come on come on come
on yes
pumpkins
pumpkins what do you see it's
working he did it w cool it's working
right now really it's
working he's got his arm around him what
an antithesis to the last season yeah
truly I mean he spent Centuries with him
it
worked oh no still too much how come the
L be
overloading all these great lens
flares it's not possible we increased
the throughput I'm Legit feeling the
frustration right now mhm the handheld
is so perfect it's so subtle but there
are just too many
branches it's still like an ocean
through a water hose just a bigger water
hose the branches of time are
duplicating and expanding uhhuh infinite
rate oh boy it's a scaling problem uh
ium will never be able to accommodate
for an infinitely growing
Multiverse well yeah I mean I love how
the setup at the Multiverse is feeling
malevolent no matter how much we
increase the throughput it will never be
enough enough never enough yeah cuz
you'll just have to always keep
increasing the throughput if it's
infinite as soon as the timeline started
branching this was doomed to happen Doom
Dr Doom Loki don't go back nothing you
can
do all right what's the singularity you
might as well just have fun hopping
through
time yall did your best I'm
sorry oh you don't need to be sorry man
you only just learned about this like
yesterday in your time and you did great
oh bring him back they're going to bring
back he who
[Music]
yes oh
[__] that's what king probably wanted
the whole time stop is this re shot I
can't tell they look great I felt what
you
feel okay wowe I wonder if he who
remains will know what's happening
you're right oh this is e as what were
you thinking trusting
me put him right up against that framing
you must not follow through it all ends
if you do I've seen it I've lived it so
many times you've been seduced by a
throne the last thing I want is a throne
you'll have to kill me does he kill
Sylvie
Jesus I me you can just keep time
slipping back to this
moment yeah he's come to
bargain why you figure out a way just to
incapacitate not what you were expecting
H don't tell me I'm a
disappointment but not even he who
remains can anticipate this huh or has
he hear me out hear me out you have to
kill
me
[Music]
I wonder how many times he has seen this
yeah if you want to stop me you'll have
to kill me come on you can figure out a
way to not kill her why do you never try
to stop her fight back do
something holy [__] could have stopped
the whole time how many times have you
been at this see he knew oh come on
you're not telling me you haven't
learned how to pause
time
yeah why don't we just uh who Holy balls
this is crazy he's conquered time this
isn't the first time we've had this
conversation how did you know I know
about the
slipping and who do you think paved that
road any guesses of course he who
remains got in one Theory right this
whole time thinking you were you were
sticking it to the system going to beat
the man and and then
whoop here he is it's interesting to see
him capturing this kind of handheld did
you really think I was just going to sit
back and let her kill me and that be it
is Zip N rip
hwr
reincarnation baby it's right there in
his name he's he who Reed we die with a
dying we're born with a dead uh-huh okay
uh
this is a lot for
you why don't you just go through this a
couple thousand more times get your
bearings you just let me
know okay when you're ready to have a
conversation oh just have the
conversation man reminds me of Lucifer
and Supernatural now such a fun way to
play the
character you figured out how to do it
on he know it was possible and what
makes you think this is the first time
we've had this
conversation
booah hold done you're my favorite you
know that when there's two of you here
you were my
favorite seems you figured it all out h
Huh interesting POV how is Victor timely
you're you're having some some some
problems with the the temporal Loom
pretending to be a Min reader SC problem
that's what he told you Victor told you
it was a scaling problem wow the
temporal Loom is a fail safe deletes
everything except the sacred timeline
huh and the TVA well that's just that's
just collateral damage no no Big Easy to
rebuild oh wow but a waste of
time nope my variants are already out
there there's too many i w stop doesn't
matter they're in a Coliseum in one
place they're all
together
the outcome to this equation
remains good Cho it Remains the Same
Song Remains the
Same shake it off it's interesting being
back here where this room is lit so much
more by the fire as compared to the last
season definitely suits The Season's
Vibe more I'll change the equation you
did just do all that math and physics
learning but the loom prevents a brutal
War where nothing survives low key not
even in the sacred timeline but how does
This Ti to
Echo peace you've ever experienced I was
here what do you think would happen to
your friends how much far ahead to see I
make the tough choices everything that's
why I get the big chair Big Boy chair
can't you see what I'm offering here but
what was the purpose of this for
me or for you I'll find another way Thor
yes we'll do the God help me is this and
around and
around and around we go where stops
nobody knows break the loom and you
cause a war that kills us all or End
Game
Killer scales and we protect what we can
ooh the trolley problem with your
variant that you
love what are you going to
do great cut wow
how far back are we going to go play out
scenes from my whole life how it's all
meant to be burdened with glorious
purpose he said it okay it looks like
someone got a hold of the set
list how do you choose who lives and who
dies this is all an origin for God of
stories it was the proper flow of time
there's no Comfort you're not going to
find Comfort at the
TVA a couple of Hunters went out on a
mission somewhere near near the Black
Sea to find a variant who's going to be
responsible for 5,000 deaths interesting
the variant is an 8-year-old
boy Slaughter the 8-year-old boy so what
must be done he had never hesitated but
that day he did happened so fast his
partner had to step in and brunin the
kid oh no is a tough decision D couple
Hunters died all because that one Hunter
he lost sight of the big picture who's
that Hunter most purpose is more burden
than Glory
and trust me you never want to be the
guy who avoids it cuz you can't live
with the burden yeah buddy great way to
use his line back at him how do you live
with it I love how this is mirroring so
much of season one right now what
happened to your partner it's not even
like a mirror is a question things
worked out fine for her she actually
became a
judge she knew the hard thing to do was
the thing that had to be
done
o damn it no there's no comfort you just
choose your
burden there's no comfort you just
choose your bur that's a poignant ass
line he went and got back to get advice
from Mobius is so beautiful he made that
hard
Choice oh
[Music]
W into the void no left
go man the meticulous mapping out of
this serious credit to the writers on
this
man let's map this out structurally is
nuts I finally learned to control the
time slipping I went back he's so weary
now it was designed to protect the
sacred timeline and nothing else I'm out
of option syia oh jeez the only way that
anything surv if I never kill he who
remains in in the first place Sylvie
might have the answer to this so you
have to kill
me unless you could go back and convince
yourself how would be able to go back
though you know maybe you can just like
take her with it that's not how time
still it's not how the force works it's
the sacred timeline or nothing it's not
enough to protect the sacred timeline
Loki damn the consequences of her
choices I grew up in Apocalypse as Loki
I've lived through enough of them to
know that sometimes it's okay to destroy
something but everything but
every if there's a hope that you can
replace that thing with something better
POV just make feel like they're talking
to us this is so strange must been so
hard to act at the
lens now there's a grander plan why
would he who remains want this to happen
he's definitely still in control I just
can't figure out what his goal is he's
becoming God of stories but we're
ultimately watching The Narrative of he
who remains right this at the end of the
day is the Kang power
[Music]
story this is incredibly sad the
burden he's been burdened with glorious
purpose yeah I love that they brought
that all back to
this if he goes out there he can't time
slip back can he
open the door
ly what are we doing I know what I want
I know what kind of God I need to be one
who serves the people for all of us for
all time
always whoa absorb all of
time wow
dude
the end of the thing SH now this looks
like a comic book oh he's back in his
comic outfit
yeah that was sick wow that's
awesome yes come the
horns oh how
striking who
magic it's the Richard E Grand
version
almost
whoa that's all I had to do this whole
time so there is no sacred
timeline it's just a which is how we get
Fox and
Sony incredible look at
that wow they look so tangible it's
actually
cool
everyone
lives or are they like necro timelines
now can actually touch the
bridges he is a God wowe he is a God so
what's happening to that part on that
timeline where he's gripping it yeah
what did happen when he just Enchanted
it was there like a natural
disaster w
cool how you going to power them
all damn this is some truly sci-fi [__]
right
here we've entered love craan territory
where are the Elder Gods Cosmic hor he's
like a full Norse God
now there it
is whoa Indiana
Jones Jehovah starts with an
eye man it's like an Assad be strong
that is
beautiful wowe
whoa sure
enough I love how it's this green magic
Rippling through all of it
wow nice stretch Zoom he making his way
to the end of
time sit and watch it all from
here
[Music]
these visuals are [__] dazzling why
do they look better than a recent Marvel
movie by a
lot look at that just tethered through
all of it his cape as part of time like
a painting
wowe beautiful that operatic Godly music
is he the man at the beginning of time
and Victor timely's at the end of time
does he represent the stories that in
and he like watches over as they
[Music]
end
whoa ourglass Fades Into
Obscurity jeeez sit on the
throne that's what he's always
wanted now do a pictoral fly get
out whoa
damn let's go to the first Iron Man
movie now Back in Black oh where we're
going to
land Tree of Life yeah oh we're on
Pandora just the mixture of the colors
of the purple and the green yeah making
it roots in a tree that was
stunning
after let me know if you need
anything's going over here talk about
restoration ah Miss
minutes are we sure she won't try to
kill us
all it's a risk I'm willing to take so
Obie may miss you okay I got those
reports on the variance of he remains oh
boy I guess one of them caused a little
bit of a ruckus on 616 adjacent but they
handled it
[Music]
so he's going to learn about himself oh
it is a good reminder those who do not
remember past or you know better off not
doomed to repeat it certainly you're
leaving you think the TVA is going to
miss a tired washed up old analyst yes
yes we will I think there is one or two
who will you're the best MCU character
got to go see what exactly it is would
been protecting if you ever want a seat
in there yeah if you get sick of those
kids they need you in
there hug it out or at least get some
pie for the road somber man were you
scared oh
yeah it's good it's good you want to be
scared you want to be
uncomfortable how big the room looks
looks around
them just so funny how the start of the
season the TV agent seems so goddamn
threatening now it just feels like
family yeah yeah people picking up the
pieces
a first edition was yellow where's
Victor let me put him back
oh hey
buddy oh is he not going to get it now
dropped off playboy
1974 then Victor Tim became a sex
addict hey oh the end of
time it's like some ethereal ponderous
Alex Garland [__] it really
is look what you can make Marvel what
you can become I really feel like it's
got that dark heart of aronowski Lac
throughout now everyone she helped prune
is going to be there waiting for their
pound of
Flesh oh snap oh that's a cool reveal
whoa
wow
oh theor Boris good thing she landed
right there
elath
it's really does look like Ohio Loki
said he could be placed back exactly
where he was left off
at and now it becomes a Wes Anderson the
Y could do a bit of work prune it no
Christ it's the best house on the
Block never look never know it's my my
policy where you going to go McDonald's
the train back to work
yeah I might just wait here for a little
bit go ride your jet ski let time
pass just actually feel time should do a
season 3 where he kills this other
version of himself
takes realizes he hates these kids yeah
made a horrible
mistake let time pass just feel t
stand in the river and let it wash over
your ankles be in the
moment oh Loki's listening they're
braided like Norse
braids
wowe I love this Tri D in
music that was so cool Still Still minor
still somber yeah it's a very sad
success day col man the day after a
Triumph is as Hollow as the day after a
tragedy man Aaron and Justin are gonna
make some beautiful Daredevil that was
some somber heaviness that vartic
article's full of [__] that was a great
finale did it say the finale was bad I
thought they we were in trouble or
something oh yeah you know Marvel's up
it's done he's the beginning of time I I
what a beautiful Arc for that character
B made Cosmic and time so grounded like
that's my exact that's a comic because I
usually say I prefer grounded stories
and characters but when you can do this
big and ground it when you've got the
emotional grounding they don't even know
what Loki did they don't know what he
did exactly do they I suppose they
wouldn't oh wow no post credit scene get
focus on
this no trailers for nothing feels like
the antithesis of a lot of recent Marvel
stuff letting the story breathe and not
having it set up 100 other things don't
be sexist Co I know what a sexist story
also somehow
racist yeah you know just cover all your
Prejudice I mean while we're here holy
[__] man it seems like it' be very
lonely to be the god of stories sitting
on that throne and then all these people
having to get in touch with their
identities and their feelings and how
they I think we all know where we're
going with this guys before we talk
about this I want to be selfish and just
sit alone in your throne yeah get yeah
that's fair that's fair there it is
thank you to better help for sponsoring
this video I've literally just finished
a therapy session and I wanted to shoot
this cuz I'm in this state of knowing
why I Champion mental health support so
much in the past few weeks work's been a
little bit hectic it's led me to miss
some sessions and I really don't like
doing that and sometimes that's when the
weight really starts to pile on a lot of
restless nights a lot of fatigue a lot
of I can't sleep even though I'm so
tired sometimes just a very deep-seated
sense of gloom and yeah every time this
time of year I get the seasonal Blues
like many of you meditating and
sometimes journaling are my daily go-tos
but sometimes they just don't cut it
when I'm trying to pinpoint why I'm down
and really especially after a session
like today therapy just really helps
clear the fog discussing the feelings is
a critical step for me especially as
someone who's diagnosed with ADHD type 2
bipolar and PTSD it's truly a
Cornerstone in my well-being and I'm not
alone in this many of us here at real
rejects are in therapy facing our own
challenges from depression into anxiety
or just needing a non-judgmental space
to voice our thoughts this year I've
been working out most days of the week
to keep my physical health strong and I
really do Champion therapy as a way to
strengthen my mental resilience and for
many betterhelp is integral to that
process There's real value in better
help's accessible and adaptable service
they match you with a licensed therapist
and provide the option to switch if
necessary ensuring the right fit for
your mental health Journey as this year
winds down and we confront life's
complexities do consider betterhelp as a
resource really happy to be partner with
them this month so you can go to
betterhelp.com rejects for 10% off your
first month again that's bet t r h
lp.com comreal rejects so join us and
moving forward stronger together thank
you again all right thank you to better
help for sponsoring this video okay um
wow I thought that was really impactful
finale uh very very strong I got to get
koi out of here and I got to edit so
there's nothing really more to say I'm
sure John likes it he likes everything
and Coy uh loves everything yeah likes
loves and then you got to hate it
because of us to give the FL I got a
nitpick yeah I mean so it's a sneak
preview balance are you saying you're
the god of stories and how revie are you
writing the story of our reviews yes um
but no Coy why don't you quickly explain
what the god of stories is so I love the
story of the god of stories because it
actually mixes in with a meta narrative
without actually being meta so in the
meta Narrative of Deadpool for example
or She-Hulk it is a roing the fourth
wall or breaking the fourth wall
acknowledging the reader in Loki's use
of the fourth wall it's actually
acknowledging the house of ideas and the
house of ideas is what they used to call
the bullpen the place that Marvel wrote
their stories the house of ideas was the
concept of creation itself in the Loki
story of the god of stories they made
the house of ideas a a tangible finite
element which he was the first one that
was able to remember his visit to the
house of ideas so throughout comic
history in this story other people had
visited the house of ideas but no one
had heard remembered so Loki made a deal
with then and now these these abstract
entities of pure storytelling and in
making a deal with then and now and upon
remembering the house of ideas itself he
is able to make things real by way of
remembering them and telling them as a
story so he's able to articulate what
reality is by way of him planting the
memory him manifesting it and then him
actually creating it in real time so
it's rapid creation through the powers
of then now and the house of IDE as
itself and so this was the visual
manifestation of that of basically he's
the one at the beginning of time
controlling the timelines because he's
the one that needs to Monitor and create
like pure creation so my interpretation
of this is that Kang is the destroyer by
monitoring and thinking that's the
answer he's at the end of time not a
destroyer in the literal sense but that
it's the it's the the atrophy the the
the the the dismay the decay of time
he's at the End of Time whereas Loki
with the green and the Lush and the
other side of colors is at the beginning
of time which is why it's said after
period for the TVA so so he literally is
creation and in a way he uh Kang is
destruction by being the Conqueror of
something so now there's a more giant
more abstract Ora Boris yeah that's
beautifully put wow you did that very
efficiently thank you well done yeah
that was not an easy story no it wasn't
I was like a little worried how I'm
gonna get through this dense dense thing
yeah well yeah I mean but in the context
of the sto of the show itself I think
they they don't ever call him the god of
stories here no I mean this is kind of
the origin of it but they don't we
haven't seen him storying it up yet no
no and he's burdened with that glor like
I love the Glorious purpose like cycling
back because before it was his arrogance
of wanting to have purpose his arrogance
of wanting a throne and through that
burden he became malevolent and I love
that now he's burdened with glorious
purpose and the weight of the throne so
his burden and that speech about purpose
is so beautifully anoris yeah and burden
with glorious boredom you know I can
imagine how I mean while being in touch
with the timelines and seeing every
single story that is unfolding you know
God of stories allows for a bit of a
narrative control and it's interesting
for Loki to be a villain who has arked
into this ultimate power following a
comic book Arc yet he is the um
benevolent uh Counterpoint to to King
and is this something I mean there's
always a conversation about they need
the balance they need the antithesis do
you think he who remains still wanted
this in the end I think that it always
had to occur otherwise there's no
creation yes I think this was all a path
that M like was made to happen there was
no alternative see that's I love this
season a lot because this committed a
little bit more I can imagine there
could be things about like I want to
rewatch it already CU I'm like I feel
like there's probably a thing or two
that I probably missed watch season one
and two together yeah yeah and I as I
love the dovet tale of how both of these
really connect very well it tells that
multiversal angle where a lot of it is
when you hold a mirror up to yourself
it's not just Multiverse Cameo look this
person is played by this person instead
I've never not wanted Deadpool more like
this this ver the way they did this it
wasn't even necessarily Multiverse it
was more time travel right um but it
told this the concepts of multiv the
Thematic things of Multiverse that I
love told through this time travel story
this narrative and watching how every
character comes into confrontation with
their own choices the weight of it the
the the basic point of accountability I
would say you know where along in the
tandem of action and events is the
fulcrum point of all these situations
yeah it was beautifully told because
it's very it's very philosophical and
it's a a lot of it is a head scratcher
and I like
the I I think there's a level of bravery
they decided to take because part one
only kind of touches on something that
could be a little difficult to grasp and
I think here they left a lot up to you
really got to pay attention this time I
was worried I couldn't explain it and
I've read it yeah yeah they they really
make you pay attention very very close
where you can you kind of pick up on
some of the details but I imagine this
is the kind of ending where people will
be going what is the ending expl I need
to know for once I think this merits
some videos on the internet saying it
does like it's a it is a very complex
and you know like the word dense is
often thrown around when it just means a
lot yeah uh but it's more than just
meaning a lot like that it is it it is
really con deconstructed through its
core there a theme and discussions
throughout and I love that we also still
did get moments of reference like the
you know 616 adjacent being the quantum
realm with it seems like Easter egg it
seems like Kang will go from that
version of himself as he remains to
being not that particular one but a
variant was referenced as being like a
one linear path so I'm really curious
will we I mean a court decision pending
but will we see he who remains K will we
see that will we see that version of him
again if things uh shine in major uh
favor and Justice is in his side of
whatever happens wow he could explain um
the god of stories really well but then
this subject I'm scared of what the
future will say about the thing if I'm
on the wrong side of knowing I'm the un
knowing god in a chair of
pink just time Sid back to this moment
say something different and as Justice
prevailed and things were due and I have
a feeling the verdict will go this
way well note I gave no conclusion to
that ellipses uh but I I'm curious uh
storytelling wise if we'll see he
remains again if Kang as instructed it
would seem they're doubling down on that
Kang being our Kang um because you know
they asked about another variant of him
it's just a beautifully open story while
still giving closure yeah I mean it's
like what I love about the he who
remains is
that like some versions of K King's more
of like a time like it's it's funny how
he's being pitched in the MCU as like
this multiversal thing but but he's I
think he's more Associated as like a
time traveler a weirdo yeah weirdo time
travel pops up like that's a weird guy
and in that book I recommended you I was
like oh I get this weird guy but but
even in that he's a time it's more of
time traveling but but everyone's kind
of associated with the multiversal stuff
right yeah because of how he's been
pitched in the MCU and I I think what
what's so cool about he who remains is
like while he doesn't Dawn more of the
classic look as we saw in quantam Mania
he is sort of like the uh ultimate Lex
Luther of sorts just it's just a brain
conglomerate the genius That We crave
from Kang and when he shows I'm like man
he is the ultimate threat like we need a
I do think we still need that
Singularity of a threat of like we need
at least one king to latch on to as
that's like Prime King that we got to
fear and then multiversal King seems
scary because we got this guy you know
and and I feel like when he who remains
is there just that power of knowledge
and foresight and navigation and
patience you know um is so great and I
just like again the opposite the
mirroring that they did with going back
to season one The PV shots like you kept
mentioning like I when they were like
talking to us when it was like hello
Loki giving a monologue at me I'm
uncomfortable cuz it's supposed to be it
was so good how do you feel during it
Sean oh I mean I was it's a very
emotionally kind of rich I don't know
they cast such a PA over everything and
there is such kind of a somber baleful
tone throughout it and it's interesting
because this does feel like the end of
something and the start of something but
this I like that they left it all on the
table in that for for the first time I
am actually quite pleased there was
nothing after the credits not even a
Loki will return for right now this is
the end of something and I am saddened
by that in an appropriate way but I
appreciate that because it really earned
just yeah every heart swell every heart
skip of a beat you know and uh yeah I'm
going to miss I'm going to miss so many
things but I'm also fascinated to see
what this becomes yeah and inspires I
think this ties Downey's Iron Man as my
favorite Arc Landing like going from the
the Mischief arrogant to the god of
stories in his throne that he doesn't
want well I love that it's such an
ironic tale for him right yeah like this
is this is completely ironic he creates
and he wanted to destroy and like he
matured into creating like he gets the
true burden of leadership like it's so
lonely and the most physical
manifestation I love that Jos Sweden
wrote like cursed with glorious purpose
cuz it sounded cool yeah I mean he's
just I mean it had a purpose then but
now it has a purpose this has a real
purp title of the damn episode yeah it's
he's he's lonely at the top and he it
real leaders normally don't want to be
the real leader he keeps rejecting
throne and power throughout this season
and he just has to take it unwillingly
and those horns we we all mentioned
separately as like they they felt
tangible they had weight the crown
looked heavy and those horns felt like
they were against him but part of him I
loved when he had like the Garb just
manifest but then it just felt so like
it's natural but man it looks awful like
it looks awful to wheel I thought it was
really multi-layered in its emotion it's
an emotionality like it was beautiful
but it was also very tragic yeah it was
um empowering and hopeful but also
incredibly sad well it starts off in in
such a I think it was smart to start
with a very fun kind of timey wiy thing
where it's like oh he's going just back
to different points and he's like
rushing through it and he's like okay
Chop Chop business as usual you go down
the thing and then we oh we try again
and I'm going to spend a thousand years
learning stuff like it starts off in a
very sort of fun place for this kind of
story that's like it gives you your cake
up front it's a good point the pacing is
a really good point and what I will say
too uh one thing that I've often said
throughout this season about Loki's
personality of I kind of miss some of
that fun side of Loki seeing who he
arked into by the end of this I'm like
oh way that actually works really well
like you wanted I remember episode three
were like I miss fun Loki and I was like
I think we'll either get him back or
it'll earn it and like I was hoping it
would I didn't think would' go here but
this really earned the season this this
episode was Loki the show because of the
rest of the season yeah yeah yeah like
we all hoped yeah but I never would have
imagined this story cuz they were just
kind of pitching him as like serious TVA
agent but the way they TI it to like a
new epic height in in a in a very
ethereal way in a in a manner that you
kind of wouldn't expect but it still
feels like we naturally got here instead
of just going like big action scene or
like big debate yeah after big debate
and I love how this it's End season
mirrors season 1 in such a way of just
like the the Revelation and again that
or Boris effect of what you're talking
about of how last one ends with he who
remains you do bring he who remains back
but he he essentially ends up becoming
the opposite version of he who remains
was still fulfilling a similar role like
wow what a powerful and stepping out of
time itself and I really like what you
said about the pacing because I think
the frenetic pacing in the opening made
the end somberness feels so much more
like you're tired like we had to go like
and I'm tired I'm glad that was one
episode like it felt so good as an hour
of just like we lived through a lot
because he he did briefly become super
TV agent he did briefly like we lived it
in this yeah it's this like vibrating
you know shifting thing that slowly kind
of Finds Its way and then calms to a you
know steady resolve and I didn't want to
talk like that that gelatinous phase I
was just like whoa that was so stunning
yeah it hits you in a different way uh
again beautiful music throughout I
really appreciate the Craftsman [__] and
Craftsman [__] the Craftsman [__]
Craftsman [__] Craftsman [__] that they
throw down that [__] they CRA house that
Craftsman [__] the the way they craft uh
together and like the story of this is
really that's really hard to write
something like this like structurally I
could just imagine that whiteboard or or
like all those index cards I cannot
imagine it's the Charlie Day for sure
yeah when they're mapping the season
like this really feels like a complete
this felt like a showrunner like threw
this one together yeah and season one
and two felt like it was all a plan and
it was literally a different team I love
that season two was a whole different
Squad I'm like how did you do this from
that like you guys found seeds that you
seems like you planted you weren't there
to plant them it's just funny how you Lo
it in you have you have the Marvels out
right now where I think the even if you
like it I think the general consensus is
that it's mess
everyone says it it it also really
represents a lot of Marvel's problems
the problems that we all have but the
people who like it had fun with it and
this is the same day and yeah and it's
just kind of crazy how you have the ju
abity of an or por with real chaos and
Decay and atrophy and what story
creation can be you have like yes this
one is not as fun nowhere near it
doesn't aim for fun but damn is it like
composed as [__] from every aspect of
film making to storytelling and acting
all of it and pacing at it every every
nugget of what someone on set is
required for before during and after
it's all present here in a way that
speaks so such loud volumes and then the
other one is but it's fun you know don't
the MCU Decay and it's it's so
interesting to get both sides
the same week I would be fascinated to
know how this and this doesn't even have
a Sor it's just funny like this doesn't
even have a post credit scene it's the
opposite the just talking about the post
SC the other one had such an important
postcard scene it's such a messy film
yeah it makes me curious how they made
this because this doesn't feel like you
could have done like modular re-shoot
and stuff like that and I'm sure this is
the first one of thato without no
re-shoot on the show it shows it shows
they they locked those scrips ahead of
time and hey maybe they had some stuff
with the earlier TVA you know Mutiny bit
but like yeah it really feels like they
locked everything and mapped this out
ahead of time yeah there's no way to go
back and like let's check that no no
this is done this is buttoned up yeah I
love how they brought it back to how
he's a God and what and what a god with
power can do it's about
responsibility and realizing that yeah
it's it's not defining what that means
and then inflicting that on everybody
else it's just accepting what it means
to be in that position of God
all right Coy uh you got to get out of
here I got to edit uh but can you wrap
us up in 30 seconds what you think this
ending means for the future of the MCU
especially Eko uh I obviously ekko's
next so it's G to tie in Loki's gonna
open the season and go like death um
it's uh I believe in 30 seconds what's
gonna happen is we're gonna have the
elements so distractive of my own joke
being so offensive um the idea of
opening the show uh as we go further the
The Narrative show that is Marvel I do
think we're going to see elements of of
the god of stories not directly
represented I think there is a chance
we'll see him in secret Wars I think
there's a chance we see him briefly in
Kang Dynasty as we see time unraveling
and like time being conquered but I
wouldn't count on Kang Dynasty
necessarily I would assume secret ORS
it'd be a big moment it'd be a big pop
and he's so overpowered he's almost like
a Celestial like um like a Living
Tribunal I could see him on the plane of
the gods that are more like the ones we
met in Elemental I mean uh um eternals
the more like that level of God so I
could see it in secret War but what I
think is going to happen going forward
is we see Kang depending on how the
story goes be introduced in more
narratives and we build to how we've met
time unraveling working for Kang being
on so many disperate parts we see how
powerful is in different places but the
big thing for Easter egg hunters is all
those timelines mean Fox Sony all those
things so we're going to see that this
unraveling and the keeping instead of
the decaying the not pruning is allowing
these universes to collide so the only
thing we're getting for a film next year
is Deadpool the events of this are how I
believe Deadpool is going to relate I
think Deadpool can travel through them
because the time Turner but I think
because of what just happened here
they're colliding so incursion events
are going to be timelines visualized by
planets and dimensional folds because of
the end of this episode which is
beautiful because it is actually what
fige promised with the stabbing of Kang
that is what started all of this because
that's what had to not happen in order
for this Multiverse to occur so that Ora
Boris is now complete but the launching
Point into the Collision of all these
things is where we're going to start
this next phase they should end this
phase here and call that the next thing
cuz it's a lot cleaner but they haven't
had a map for a little bit so I think
Deadpool is the beginning of the
unraveling of the events caused by the
end of this year and if K gets to stay
it'll be him uh building power setting
up to Kang Dynasty and then ultimately
Secret Wars where we might see Loki
again Amen to that that was well done
dude that's crazy I love Comics it's
crazy how he became like how he just he
wanted to be a dictator and he ends up
becoming the exact opposite he becomes
the benevolent God creation just want to
have free will it's just so funny and I
love that he wears green the color of
creation like there's so much Beauty in
this yeah and then with the with the
opposite of like King's colors his
colors are purple and it's like green
too and the tree of life being purple
and green like the flowering Purple
colors too you know God damn it's good
TV all righty guys uh that was brilliant
I love that um what did you guys think
leave your thoughts down below what was
your favorite moment from this thank you
KY for being here guys thank you for
being joining us I'll catch you all
soon